hi
i'm khush madhya and i will be
presenting our work on agnostic learning
with unknown utilities
this is joint work with peter bartlett
ankar dragan and jacob steinhardt
in classical decision problems one often
begins with a data set
consisting of n data points these
consist of feature or context vectors x
i
and corresponding labels or decisions y
i the central objective in most
scenarios is to learn a classifier
to predict the labels y correctly given
context vectors
x within this paradigm
most works if not all implicitly assume
that all mistakes are equally costly and
that each scenario x
is equally important in reality though
this is often not the case for instance
consider the classification system
designed for a self-driving car
the cost of mispredicting a roadside
post of box
versus that of missing out on a stock
sign can actually be very different
furthermore consider the two scenarios
shown in the picture
one where a person is crossing the road
and the other where the person is
walking
far away from the roadside clearly
identifying the person correctly
is far more important in the first case
as compared to the second one
in our work we posit that each decision
taken by the learner
has a context dependent utility or a
negative cost
furthermore key characteristics of this
utility function
are that a it is unknown to the learner
a priori
before the task begins and b that it is
necessary for the human to communicate
it to the learner in some form
given this unknown utility the question
here is how do we communicate this
function to the learner
the first option is to possibly get a
human expert to write down this complex
utility function mathematically
and hand it over to the learner however
this option can be prone to serious
errors
since it is very hard for an expert to
imagine all possible scenarios a priori
and encode them in the utility function
another option is to allow the agent to
learn this utility function from
observed decisions
such a paradigm has been studied in the
economics literature
as learning from revealed preferences
and in the machine learning community
as inverse reinforcement learning the
main idea here
is to allow the learner to infer the
underlying utility function
by exhibiting optimal decision making in
different scenarios
however most of the techniques studied
here assume that this utility function
lies in some well-specified class of
functions say
linear in some feature space and it
offers no guarantees on their
performance
in the face of slight misspecification
hence both these options are not
actually suitable to communicate this
unknown utility function
in order to overcome the limitations of
these existing options
we introduce our framework of agnostic
learning with unknown utilities
wherein we place no assumptions on the
underlying utility function
you start formally
the learner is presented with a data set
of n points
each of which is sample iid from some
unknown distribution d
we denote by script f the decision
function class
wherein each function f is a mapping
from the context space
x to decision space y further
we denote by you start the true utility
function
which is again unknown to the learner
this utility function maps contexts and
corresponding decisions to rewards in a
bounded interval
lastly there is an information oracle
with which the learner can interact and
get more information
about the different decisions why and
the underlying utility you start
as i mentioned earlier our framework
moves away from placing any assumption
on the underlying utility function u
star
and instead posits that the decision
making function can only be selected
from this restricted class
f given this framework
the objective of the learner is to
output a function f hat
such that it has small excess risk when
evaluated on this unknown utility
function u star
observe that this is just an evaluation
criteria and that
true utility is never revealed to the
learner
with this setup the key question here is
what should be this information oracle
we would ideally like this article to be
powerful enough to make learning
feasible
but it should not be overly complicated
for human experts to answer the queries
before we discuss this issue in detail i
wanted to mention that
going forward we will restrict our
attention to the binary classification
problem
where the label space y consists of two
labels a blue label and a green label
coming back to the information oracles
the first contender for such an article
is the value oracle
in this article given a context x and a
decision
the human expert provides the exact
value of the underlying utility function
however note that the underlying utility
function can be quite complex
and this actually makes it very hard for
human experts to accurately provide
these value judgments
this actually makes it infeasible to
deploy such an oracle in practice
on the other hand it is often easier for
humans to provide comparative evaluation
based on these utilities
for instance one can query the human
with a context and a pair of decisions
and it can respond by indicating which
of these two
has a higher utility we call this the
comparison oracle
such comparative feedback however is
severely limited
in the information it provides to the
learner
for instance consider the problem where
we have three clusters of data points
x1 x2 and x3 the color of the data point
here
indicates which of the two decisions has
a higher utility
for instance for the cluster x1 the
green decision has a higher utility than
the blue one
the shaded areas mark the predicted
decisions for the two classifiers f1
and f2 observe that both classifiers f1
and f2
make the same number of mistakes f1
predict mispredicts
x3 while f2 mispredicts x1
also just by interacting with the
comparison oracle
no learner will be able to understand
the relative costs of these mistakes
indeed no learner can understand the
precise tradeoffs between the different
mistakes
and one can actually show a strong
statement which is that any algorithm
will suffer an excess risk which will be
order one
thus this comparison oracle while being
easy to implement on the human side
is actually information theoretically
limited
we can go to the other extreme and one
can imagine an extremely powerful oracle
which we call the infinite comparison
oracle
this oracle takes in two functions f1
and f2
and outputs which one of those has a
higher utility
when evaluated on the true distribution
d
note that this article can actually be
used by a learning algorithm to figure
out the best decision function in the
class f
however it places all the burden of
learning on the human expert
asking them to effectively compare
decisions across an infinite number of
contexts
thus while being information
theoretically optimal this article
is practically infeasible to implement
to overcome these limitations of
existing elicitation mechanisms
our work proposes a new type of
comparison oracle
which we call the k comparison oracle
this type of information feedback
interpolates between the vanilla and the
infinite comparison
it gives the human expert a bucket of k
different contexts
x1 to xk and two sets of associated
decision vectors
the human is then required to compare
these two bundles
and output which of these two has a
higher combined utility
note that one can recover the vanilla
and the infinite comparison oracles by
setting k equals to 1
and k equals to infinity respectively
it's import it's also important to note
here that as the order k of the
comparison oracle increases
it gets harder and harder for the human
to provide this feedback
going forward we'll focus on our problem
of agnostic learning with unknown
utilities
where the information oracle is the key
comparison oracle
we will describe our main algorithm
which interacts with the k comparison
oracle
to output a function f hat and we'll
also study its statistical properties
let's begin with our main algorithm in
this figure
the x-axis represents the different data
points
the color of each data point again
represents the decision with the higher
utility
the y-axis represents the utility gain
that is
how much additional utility can a
classifier gain by predicting green
versus blue for any particular data
point
further for illustration purposes we'll
restrict
f to be the class of threshold functions
and each function f
will therefore partition the space into
a blue and a green region
let's begin with a slightly easier
problem where the underlying utility
function u star
is actually known to the learner in this
case
the learner can simply output the
function f which maximizes the utility
on
n data points and this is also called
the empirical utility maximizer
this function f erm is known to have
good generalization properties
depending on the class of functions f
however since in our problem the utility
function u star is unknown
the learner cannot output the erm
function
instead our algorithm consists of a
two-step plug-in estimator
in the first step this estimator obtains
estimates you had
of the utility on the sample data points
by interacting with the k
comparison oracles the vertical bars on
the data points
reflect this estimation error
in the next step the learner simply
outputs the empirical maximizer with
respect to these estimated utilities
in the plot this is shown by the
threshold function
f hat alg given this procedure
i will now explain in detail how the
first step
that of estimating the utilities works
to obtain estimates you had on the
sample data points
the algorithm begins by finding the data
point x max
which has the maximum utility gain
this data point is highlighted in the
figure on the right
notice that this can actually be
obtained by simply using two comparison
queries
for instance to compare the gains of the
data points x1 and x2
we can ask a query comparing both
blue decisions for x1 and x2 with both
green decisions
this query effectively provides a
comparison between the utility gains of
x1
and x2 once we have the ability to
compare two data points
we can find the one which has the
maximum utility gain
once we have the point x max with us the
algorithm
can use this to estimate the utility
gains of each data point using k
comparisons
in order to see how consider the point x
prime
in the figure on the right for some
value of j
between 1 and k over 2 we can issue the
following k
query to the comparison oracle in the
query
we first set the first k by 2 elements
to be
points x prime and the next j elements
to be x
max such
a k query can be shown to be equivalent
to asking the human expert
whether k by 2 times the gain for x
prime is bigger
or j times the gain for x max
combining this with a binary search and
varying the values of j appropriately
one can actually obtain a 2 by k
approximate estimate of the utility gain
of x
prime similarly by iterating over
all the data points one can obtain the
estimates over the entire data set
and with this we complete the procedure
for obtaining these estimates
so just to recap our main algorithm is a
two-step plug-in estimator
in which the first step comprises
estimating utilities you had
on the sample data points by interacting
with the key comparison oracle
in the next step the algorithm outputs
the empirical utility maximizer with
respect to these estimated utilities
given this algorithm
the natural question to ask is what
about the excise risk of this estimator
which was our original objective to
begin with
our main upper bound theorem precisely
answers this question
in particular it says that the plugin
estimator
makes order n log k queries to the k
comparison oracle
and then its excess risk is upper
bounded by a sum of two terms
the first term which is a complexity
term captures the expressiveness of the
function class f
this depends on how the utility u star
interacts with the class f but more
importantly
it places no restrictions whatsoever on
this utility function u star
more formally this term captures the
rate of uniform convergence of the class
f when evaluated on the utility u star
the second term is a product of two
terms
the first is a factor of the order of
one over k
and the next one is the misprediction
error
of the optimal erm function
observe that in the well specified case
when the ern correctly predicts the
labels of each data point
this term vanishes and one does not pay
any additional error
for not knowing the utility function
thus the consequences of not knowing the
utility function
only come up in the misspecified setup
further note that this theorem provides
an example of an interesting
accuracy elicitation tradeoff
as the order k of the comparison
increases
the error decreases at a rate of 1 over
k
however as we had earlier noted
increasing this order
also makes eliciting accurate responses
from the human expert harder
thus by wearing these value of k one can
cover an entire spectrum of this
tradeoff
it's also important to note here that
our proposed algorithm is actually query
efficient
it makes order n log k queries to the k
comparison oracle
and actually any statistically efficient
algorithm
needs to make at least n queries to the
oracle to learn about the utilities on
all the data points
now given this upper bound it's a
natural question to ask
whether this additional error term uh
comprising of 1 over k
and the error of the erm classifier is
indeed necessary
or is it just a manifestation of our
analysis
to answer this we prove a lower bound
theorem which shows that for any k
greater than 1 there exists prediction
problems such that the minimax risk
of any algorithm is lower bounded by a
constant over k
thus we established that our plugin
estimator is
actually statistically minimax optimal
to conclude our artwork formalizes
a class of supervised learning problems
wherein the underlying utility function
is unknown to the learner a priority
we study a natural plug-in estimator and
established that it is statistically
minimax optimal
furthermore in the course of our
analysis we also reveal an interesting
accuracy elicitation trade-off within
this framework
please check out our paper to learn more